there's just so much concern about
censorship
or self-censoring
[Music]
it's the first time we are seeing a
global institution
in
hong kong that stands for asia and
bringing the broad depth of visual
culture
m plus a grand 646 000 square feet
visual culture museum opened its doors
to the public
the museum which took nearly two decades
to complete overlooks hong kong's iconic
landmarks
from linai han cctv wardrobe to fungi
june's 1995.2
the museum prides itself on its 8 000
artworks including 167 million dollar
collection of contemporary chinese art
donated by swiss collector ulisig
the whole opening exhibitions include
more than 1500 objects by almost 800
artists and makers many ideas
are represented by these exhibitions and
we see almost infinite possibilities for
learning and teaching
but the opening couldn't have come at a
more politically tense time
the past 20 years hong kong you know has
enjoyed relative freedoms around culture
compared to to mainland china i think
what hong kong will have to get used to
is
something that's more akin
culturally to what goes on in mainland
china
in the wake of the pro-democracy protest
that rocked the asian financial center
in 2019
beijing imposed a national security law
on the city this not only led to arrests
of more than 100 democracy activists but
planted the seeds of concern over
censorship in the art world
beijing remains resolute in his speech
in june chinese president xi jinping
laid out plans to exercise overall
jurisdiction to protect national
security in the city
it's difficult to have a normal practice
when you're busy dodging bullets
wong's floating structure paddling home
is featured at one of the six opening
exhibitions at the museum
but the hong kong artist who is widely
known for his bold performance and
artworks of the protest now lives in
self-imposed exile in taiwan
in march hong kong chief executive
carrie lam reiterated that authorities
will be on full alert to ensure museum
exhibitions do not undermine national
security
right now we have not had to make any
changes to our opening
exhibitions national security law is a
very new law we're still waiting to see
what that means
but like all institutions in any part of
the world we always work within the law
we don't break the law
the road to the museum's opening hasn't
been without controversy particularly
involving the works of dissident artist
ai weiwei
his work study a perspective tiananmen
which depicts airway gesturing to
tiananmen square isn't on display but is
listed on the website
emplous says it hasn't made changes to
its original opening plan
eyes whitewash and changan boulevard are
on display
what i can say is that what we have been
planning for the opening for the last
five years are all here and not just as
a chief curator but for all the curators
all of the programmers have to think
about what rules and regulations are and
that's not a new situation actually
you almost cannot
distinguish which one is really censored
awkward joint is just self-censorship
i think all the institutions
and plus or other cultural institutions
cannot find any balance under the
national security law that means you're
losing balance and there's no way no
space
wong who has two works in the opening
exhibition hong kong here and beyond
says there is a lack of art about the
city's dramatic political upheaval
what about the umbrella movement
arts in 2014
all those
images that was created and produced
during the entire extraditional movement
it would just go in vain it's kind of
evaporating so for me
definitely that's a blind spot
for mplus they remain undeterred by the
politics
i think the changes and transitions
affect everything but what that means is
that it builds flexibility it also
builds resilience it also tests your own
assumptions and your complacency
there's a much
different condition now you're under
this
very
very strong authoritarian control
but still art
is a possibility
to to rebel and to find a new language
and that would make the art more
powerful
so i really think
a real artist
should
challenge the system
and i think that's what m plus that's
the lesson n plus will have to learn
how do they sustain a critical practice
within that particular context
[Music]